we begin in the united states where 19
children and two teachers have been
killed in a school shooting in texas the
attack happened at an elementary school
in the town of uvalde near the mexican
border police killed the 18 year old
shooter president joe biden has ordered
flags to be flown at half-mast and he's
urging americans to stand up to the gun
lobby
another day
another mass shooting in the united
states
children and adults gunned down
when the teenage suspect opened fire at
this texas elementary school
he was believed to be armed with both a
handgun and a semi-automatic rifle
the suspect is deceased at this point
dps is assisting with the investigation
and at this point the investigation is
leading to tell us that the suspect
did act alone during this hyenas crime
president joe biden returned home
to a country reeling from another mass
shooting
asking the questions on the minds of
many
why are we willing to live with this
carnage
why don't we keep letting this happen
where in god's name is our backbone
to have the courage to deal with and
stand up to the lobbies
amid the prayers platitudes and familiar
symbols of public mourning
anger at a system
paralyzed by politics
costing the lives of ordinary americans
what are we doing
what are we doing
just days after a shooter walked into a
grocery store
to gun down african-american
patrons we have another sandy hook on
our hands
what are we doing
with 200 mass shootings in the us this
year alone
the debate over gun control has rarely
been out of the headlines
hillary clinton says america is becoming
a nation of anguished screams
this small town in texas
just the latest place you'll hear the
cries of pain
over young lives could tragically short
dw correspondent sumi somaskanda is
monitoring this story for us from
washington a short while ago she gave us
this update
terry we are getting more pictures
pieces of the picture coming in to us
and as you said 19 children dead and at
least two adults we know that others are
still being treated in the hospital we
don't know how many but we should say
that the death toll could continue to
rise among the students i want to
underline we are talking about kids who
are in second third and fourth grade so
here in the u.s that means kids from
around six years old to around 11 who
attended this elementary school and
authorities of the night have been
speaking with the families of the
victims taking dna samples to identify
children and they've said that they will
only release more information to the
public to the media once all of the
families have received
full information about their loved ones
we don't know how long that process will
take as for the shooting we know this
was a lone gunman 18 years old he
attended the high school in uvalde and
we heard that he actually shot his
grandmother before getting in the car
heading to the school he went in and
proceeded to shoot
in this classroom these classrooms it's
being reported that he had a rifle that
he purchased legally on his 18th
birthday and that he was wearing a body
armor of some sort and terry i just want
to add about this community it's a very
small community fairly close to the
mexican border heavily latino latina and
this was the end of the school year
we're hearing heartbreaking details that
in this elementary school there was
actually an honors awards ceremony just
hours before the shooting parents
attended that these kids were just a few
days away from summer vacation and now
these parents facing an unspeakable
tragedy some of them not going home with
their children
do we know anything about the motive of
the shooter sumi
authorities are trying to piece that
together right now there are federal and
local law enforcement agencies on the
ground picking apart evidence we know
from other mass shootings in the u.s
that a social media accounts are really
important and apparently this shooter
did
post some violent messages online but we
don't know terry if he attended this
elementary school at any point whether
he intended to attack the school at all
or most importantly why he would commit
this crime we're waiting for more
details to come in on that
and we heard president joe biden urging
the nation to stand up to the gun lobby
we've heard those appeals before of
course is there any chance that this
time gun laws will be changed to make
these mass shootings less likely
there seems to be very little chance of
that terry i mean as you said there was
an emotional address from president
biden demanding action we heard that
echoed across washington from democratic
senators representatives and this is
just 10 days after the racist rampage in
a supermarket in buffalo that killed 10
black americans you know there has been
bipartisan support in the house of
representatives to pass what is called
common sense gun regulation to
strengthen background checks restrict
who can access weapons but that has
always hit a wall in the senate where
republicans have blocked any efforts to
move forward and indeed we saw
republicans saying in the aftermath of
the shooting that it is time to actually
step up armed protection at schools
rather than regulation so again terry
avenue for change does look slim here
and i just want to add president biden
asking the question in his address are
we ready to take on the gun lobby
the national rifle association the nra
one of the most powerful lobby groups in
the u.s is actually holding its annual
convention in texas this weekend among
the announced speakers the former
president donald trump
simi thank you so much our washington
correspondent sumi samaskanda there
you